about what April Fool's prank got me
kicked out of school oh that's a good
one a put a rotten fish in my teacher's
desk B stole my teacher's car or C
Street during a high school football
game
I'm gonna say
I'm gonna say for fun you stole your
teacher's card that is correct will I
along with several other friends
including uh Jimmy barbutis stole our
teacher's car by lifting it we actually
lifted it and and walked away yeah
because we didn't have driver's license
it's got expelled for that I was
suspended for that yeah it must have
been a SubCom it must have been a
compact car is it Volkswagen Bug easy
yeah no big yeah big deal